an jeder schon oft der branche jetzt
zeit dass wir wieder
tolle frisur in hardheim wie ein toter
pudel tritt
morgen immer geworden geht hört doch auf
die passierten 150 geburtstag
ja das ist nicht gesagt dass der seit
drei oder im 45 die zweimal statt dass
er richtig chemie muss man sich mit dir
ja genau und wie sagt er warum schau mal
her doch ich habe hauswirth folge
ein volldepp mit einer sehr schönen
musik mit einer kurzen hose das hat man
doch wieder raus klickt dies trägt man
jetzt so der pep guardiola auf seine
gehörten darunter auch das spectaculum
hat gar keine wo sie ja aber wenn er
eine hätte dann so
einfach die ranzen meiste ansehen der
hätte sie angezogen was der hat halt die
ja so einen tollen stil genau vor allem
wieder die ohren doch formalitäten
urlaub wieder die du sitzen lassen hat
[Musik]
wie viel über die hilfe
du bist dich hätte ich nicht mit der
kärntner also du du du hast sicher
wahnsinnig verhindert also irgendwie
greift
darf ich falsch denn das ist mein mann
den ansässig sind bloß mit
anselm sowie schlappen bloß mit musik
und dann sehen was macht sie auf der
party von der baxi wir haben doch einmal
was metern gehabt aber das ist schon so
lange her da hab ich damals meinen
motorradführerschein gemacht was bei den
motorrad führerschein da waren wir zwar
noch zusammen du das sagen hätte heute
geschichte und ihr zwar
schon seit fünf jahren
[Gelächter]
bist du auch wieder liiert meister so
einer wie der bleibt er nicht lang
alleinige ja stimmt ja hab mich noch
einmal umgedreht und schon was sie da
fündig tamara hat tamara kunde herzen
wir kennen uns schon seit der kindheit
bleibt aber
wie ich ihn kennengelernt habe ihn
gefragt wo ist denn man all den jahren
aber
jetzt ist der anteil bei mir und hat mir
ein ratsantrag macht bei unserem urlaub
in den malediven auf den magnetischen
geschäfts auf den malediven das ist
wirklich super
angeblich haben es doch wird dann
schlimme lackaffen klage
wir schauen die den
ausschlag auf die haben ganz großes
extrem damals maul und ein ganz kleines
stumm ist ein
lustiges lied
die kamera arbeitet die kinder ja ja das
wahrscheinlich ganz schön hart dass wir
so intellektuell mit dem stoff mitkommt
oder in die machen nichts mit stoff der
so mit fingerfarben
und ansätze als er eine modelkarriere
ist
das modeln war jetzt einmal zeit lang
ganz lustig aber jetzt brauche ich eine
neue herausforderung
ich bin jetzt zehn tv branche
eingestiegen steinhauser bau in ein bis
zwei jahren habe ich da eine
führungsposition
du bist beim steinhauser bau die aber
erst seit kurzer zeit das ist eine
riesen firma du kennst du doch bestimmt
oder
ich arbeite auch das okay da werden uns
bestimmt einmal trifft vor allem wenn
ich auf der karriereleiter an dir vorbei
rasch und so bewusst
[Gelächter]
wie findest du eigentlich dass mir mein
neuer nachname steht
steinhaus
steinhaus ev
und selbst
steinhauser sieht steinhauser wie josef
stein haus genau josef oder
josef also so langsam macht mir die
partie von der partie so richtig spaß
und am montag wieder die 8 kantige
rausschmeißt 06 einfach als
herausforderung
wie alt wird sie eigentlich